all right ever since i reviewed the asus
transformer prime a couple weeks ago
i've gotten a lot of questions about the
dock i mean it's called the transformer
after all so what exactly does it
transform into and how good is it the
tablet is without a doubt about i mean i
think we settled that in the review but
can it transform into a full laptop
replacement let's check this out
introducing the asus transformer prime
tf201 plus its dock first of all the
dock itself is actually pretty
impressive it's a little bit smaller
than a full size keyboard yes but the
keys are actually pretty comfortable to
type on despite their size and you can
also see that there are a number of
android specialty keys so on the left
hand side you have a dedicated home
button and a dedicated search button and
on the right hand side you get arrow
keys and a dedicated android menu button
and up top is a smashing array of
buttons we have a back button a wi-fi
toggle a bluetooth toggle a track
padlock brightness controls and an auto
brightness button a camera shortcut a
browser shortcut a settings shortcut
media playback and controls with volume
and your lock slash unlock button which
i actually found to be the most useful
of them all brilliant
it also adds a full size usb port to the
tablet yes full size i'm looking at you
other tablet
along with its own charging port and led
on the left hand side it has its own
charging port because it has an internal
battery which it does charge and
dispense first so when you're hooked up
to the tablet with the keyboard i found
that it uses the dock battery then the
tablet battery so when you can you know
use a tablet for hours while it's
plugged in pop off the keyboard and
still have a 100 battery left on the
tablet so that's always really nice so
thanks to all of your comments of course
i was actually wondering to myself can
this replace a laptop is there enough
power here is there enough functionality
so i hooked it up and well i got to
trying to use it trackpad and all and it
actually got pretty crazy i found myself
flying through the ui opening apps
searching stuff and using the hardware
keys the way i wouldn't have even
thought of before having this keyboard
multi-touch gestures were also
especially impressive as the trackpad
supports long press tap to click and
multi-touch for easy navigation around
android 4.0 ice cream sandwich
but seriously this was pretty pleasant
to use and what's really nice is you can
still use the touch screen and the
keyboard at the same time so you know
stuff like the multitasking button or
stuff you want to do on the screen they
still work so it all blends together in
a very dynamic
wicked one-of-a-kind experience that i
really enjoyed a lot now as you probably
know asus also happens to make some
well-respected ultrabooks and
lightweight laptops and the most awkward
part of the comparison was actually
brace yourself
opening it up
laptops built to be laptops are weighted
and built just right to open up just
like in the commercials that is sexy
tablets that aren't built to be laptops
not so much i mean maybe i'm nitpicking
now but that happened to bug me a lot
that it wasn't that easy to open so in
the end it kind of begs the question
does the transformer prime with the dock
compete with a full-fledged laptop well
to be fair it does match some of the
features that netbooks or ultrabooks
these days have
including the instant on feature
ultrabooks with ssds can resume from
sleep in maybe two to three to four
seconds and actually opening up the
transformer prime it'll actually resume
from sleep in maybe less than one second
typically so yeah to be fair it matches
that feature there's also the thinness
factor a lot of ultrabooks are very very
thin to make them portable and also
light and well built transformer prime
is not really that much different it's
very very thin the dock is very thin so
put together they are really well
connected and a pretty solid well-built
and lightweight portable machine so so
far it's looking pretty good and let's
not forget that the transformer prime
and the transformer prime dock put
together still probably cost less than
the machine you're watching this on it's
very inexpensive compared to most
laptops so can it replace your laptop
well here's the thing look at what you
do on your laptop if you do pretty light
consumption right now maybe watching
youtube videos
answering emails reading emails word
processing sometimes some light photo
editing you're gonna be just fine with
the transformer prime it handles all
that and the tegra 3 is an absolute boss
so you won't have full size apps like
you know microsoft word or photoshop or
just heavy hitters like that but if you
don't need that you know take a look in
the android market and if you find the
apps that you want and they actually
work for you you'll be set the laptop
the transformer prime most closely
resembles is the samsung chromebook i
mean if you think about it the
transformer prime is really a quad-core
chromebook either way if you enjoyed
this video thanks for watching i hope it
helped you out if you're considering
this particular purchase give a thumbs
up on this
if you give a thumbs up on this video
i'd really appreciate it and uh thanks
for all the the ratings and the
subscriptions guys really do
appreciate every single one of you so
like i said thanks for watching this
video and i'll talk to you next one
mkbhd signing out
peace
you